you
a small group of 15 for this one
Botvinnik tournament king of the hill
tournament one-minute time control 30
minute tournament let's see what we get
okay
Wow it's the King get just gonna run out
in the center right away
I want the up to square for my king I
don't want a queen exchange cuz their
king is gonna run like a bandit right
towards the center oh here we go
taking with my take me Kings a fighter
huh I'm gonna pin my king is closer
let's go for a queen trade I love Queen
trades where my king is this close this
is already a win isn't it my Kings
faster um let's go here how are you
stopping this mouth oh nice can I get
away with this drop my knight King takes
pawn of threatening rook check and then
King here oh oh no no no I was so close
I was so close
hmm let me in there man let me in there
I'm on the knight trade rooks I got it I
got a rook check and then mate huh huh
the old clearance tactic for king of the
hill back to tournament land
kingi for best bite test I'll take it
our rocket start for important first
game win site update in progress it says
let's see um okay the site update is
officially complete if I was in game I
think we would gain some time like 15
seconds each all right 22 players
handful more entered Kovac IC is in
there and we have Hovick around to the
sneaky pelvic let's try to Scandinavian
yeah I like moving the f-pawn king of
the hill for this little cubbyhole king
of seven let's do it mm-hmm is he really
safe there
let's defend here for starters Oh
my queen will be there this is probably
a move huh shut it down
d5 and then here mmm
let me hold off on that queenside castle
I think so my king is still a little a
little close queenside castle is fine
more simplified it is I think the better
I'd like to have Queens off Queens c4
can also go for checkmate right let's do
this
Queen f7 on b3 no I could take the
knight it's a little fork I'm on h2 yeah
let's pick them up okay oh that's a
queen why am I not getting towards the
center my king I know how much time King
here next I can't stop it can you not
for long you bugger you the bugger we're
getting there soon enough though they
resigned back to tournament wow it's
been a while since I play king of the
hill okay what so much for that rocket
start was that what the site adjustment
was all about ah-huh he undid that huh
undid it they undid it
it was undone no rocket start for you
alright this is to prevent b5 b6 b5 idea
they're running into this tempo move in
another tempo move Queen is close to
trapped who their self pin I can't get a
step up huh
scary he's weak Wow living very very
dangerous here is black oh yeah
rook to c1 I'm also on there Queen don't
forget about the Queen all right let's
win some stuff no I feel like I don't
even want to take that yeah I do it's
free completely free more free stuff all
right I didn't even see that they moved
there on the Queen
I want my king up on e4 let's go King
king e4 in two or three threat get out
of there
- chairman yeah I guess that's what the
site update was all about okay I have
eight zambano has on a tear 15 was he
doing some wild King uh moves right in
the beginning
space space huh alrighty
that's a nice home for a peace
what
take out this guy in this I want to take
out the defenders of d4 let's keep the
tension
all right I can get crazy here um I
think I could do this
no take what the pun I always dream of
that unstoppable no I just stop ibly
have to take the bishop they didn't see
that they could take the bishop and stop
king deform back to tournament 2012
eight twenty two minutes left okay I
thought wasn't this two player I played
it around one though I'm confused I'm
very confused I thought I I don't know
wow that's a wild King
I don't like that at all holy cow really
let's do this let's go here first
I need to have control over this square
before I move my night like this oh my
goodness this is bad I'm allowing them
they're getting away with this nonsense
it's nonsense
give me the Queen take my night I get
your queen aha you're flushed back
take that hmm nice
um let's give a check I don't know we'll
go here and I get to give a a check to
the King and now my king is gonna fly up
here
Finn's push the fine I feel like I give
mate I like and like a regular way I'm
pre moving something that's unprotect
I'm the stopper King here one day take
them you know you want to take him it's
gotta hear you shouldn't do that yeah
I'm in big trouble I'm in big trouble
oh I didn't have anything there Chuck oh
I gotta win I had a little sore it's
ridiculous oh my goodness you have to
just think so different man ah oh man
all they had to do is take my rook in
there take on e4 okay you can cut out
one two three ah yeah let's let's play
with some fixed pawns that went that way
it's what I don't know I don't know what
I'm trying to say
okay
oh let's back up maybe we could just
play a regular game of chess how about
that can we just play a regular game for
once already
I'm not queenside I think queenside is a
good option in king of the hill
get out of there got no business being
there
step up Fork is met with Knight f5 look
at you
fanciness man fanciness knight there is
that what you're planning mmm ooh I'll
take that
that's a fork clean there scary
scariness look at this so
dreamed of this initial position
shriveled tripled be pawns Wow three
pawns gotta do some damage
couldn't take king here's game over no
man I'm not giving up that square no way
you take care I take there me just want
to get rid of the rook and what do you
got deflection and then mate next there
we go back to tournament slithered on in
there 25 but without fire I have fire in
20 17 minutes plenty of times thirty
players in this one Johnny DJ I think
just finished no well yeah maybe
finished but I I'm not paired up with
Johnny D all right
well let's pin them for starters
keep the pin okay
I guess the Knights dropping into d4 ya
need to challenge this bugger this
bugger I'm also saying that right now
who else is saying it right now no I'm
not even preparing to play this move
especially now ooh I like that
don't get any crazy ideas King I'm going
towards the center I guess here let's
just step over what are you up to King
thirty seconds let's flush him back King
is officially cut off there we go
now we're getting there no we are
definitely cooking I always pre move
that back to tournament 27:24 I have
fire is he in a game yes he just started
go orbit call him win that game put a
dent in oh what a speed bump there
woo spinal taps in there couple couple
goose eggs there Johnny deejay Johnny
deejay with the question mark
I think um when there's fixed pawns in
the center it tends to be more of a
regular chess type game I want to keep a
grip over efore take me
let's kick them around a little bit pins
hmm what's wrong with that
um I think it's here I don't want a
castle Wow
didn't see that one okay ooh they didn't
see I mother Queen okay my king is
stepping up two squares away now
all right King next up these squares
controlled take this pond King up next
clearance and then they're from me next
they resigned back to tournament I have
a lead by one point width fire big game
coming up he just finished
I'm back one point I have fire big big
game with 13 minutes and change
remaining here we go oh boy let's see
what he throws at me
this is some some opening trick we got
going on here is that what this is that
what we have going on
pin that night yeah I know man I know I
know it's tense it's a tense game oh
he's already threatening me with that I
didn't see it
holy cow
I could take there huh oh I think I'm
lost I am lost oh man
I can't stop king d4 or can I
a miraculous save no way take them take
them take them take them somehow we're
fighting
it's a giant fight um get out of there
night
I need this square oh man I'm flushed
back not cool
oh this is a big trouble
oh yeah that's that's me that's me yeah
you can't you can't allow King D for
it's a slight air that's slightly just a
slight air right there to allow to allow
King to one of these four you're gonna
you're gonna want to make an adjustment
next time on that one
oh man that's an interesting idea
just that gambit to undermine my Center
I haven't seen that one before I think I
like that one enough to try it myself
that was nice well done he's got a
five-point lead
yes he does still 11 minutes left
okay throw your knight in there give
that pond up huh
who cares about the f-pawn no boy gonna
drop in their pond takes I want to get I
want to get here we make that happen
mmm
rook takes no no no sorry if I got loud
there we go it's closed clean here gotta
support that mmm
so tense Wow what a cool move I love
that move Wow I love that move that's a
really good one this is okay but yeah
that's a nice replay very nice Wow
I'm in big trouble
yikes to go for regular mate try to win
this with regular mate
oh boy oh boy
terrible pre-move attempt
growling time burners that's all I got
kitchen sink tactics kitchen sink
tactics oh man Matthew joy you that was
a killer move man
that's the star over the tournament
can't outdo that when g5 I love it
ah that was such a good move oh I got
this beast again okay I have to try
something different these uh this gambit
line tough okay he's not moving as a
disconnection issue the players left the
game uh-oh Oh who's back in the mix here
is he's having a connection issue
I got awarded a win for that one okay
eight minutes and change a very lucky
break there for me okay eight minutes
and change yeah something's something's
up here he wouldn't have just quit he
must have had something uh some
connection issue huh all right we're
gonna try uh I'm gonna try out for the
bird is the word
for king of the hill maybe
is the bird the word maybe yeah get out
of there
maybe even take with the King now
probably too early huh let's let's build
up a little bit in the center yeah I
like my King position right here
g4f five here we go okay with an
exchange my king is really really strong
right here okay
losing the a pond but my king is still
in the center how could I
undermine this stuff okay I could play
94 let's take your first let's drop him
in there why not take that pond I won't
make oh nice shot nice in-betweener
right there don't know what that's doing
I want to get to this square isn't my
pond running though got a touchdown oh
he snuck in there behind enemy lines 35
32 he's back on the horse he got another
game in there I have fire three back oh
man I don't know how to call this one
this guy also is on my heels the guy in
third place he has fire four back
six and change okay let's do this
there we go
all right run to the center quick
threatening the night I could take the
pawn King here for me you're getting a
little too crazy if the knight moves I
get this that's a check and I get here
the King has to go forward oh they
didn't do that
dr. tournament quick win Wow the the
King didn't move forward d3 or e3 that
was super quick 36 with fire 35 he lost
oh we got another game against him let's
keep it shut down
all right King let's go here all right I
like my king position again I get this
in to check and this is hitting with
check and I want to stop Bishop c5 now
let's take that out let's get the night
out look here
get that Bishop away hmm
I'll take sneak my king up this has to
be good um or does it take me hmm no
that's not working there's Queen check
here yep they called my bluff I'm still
gonna try to get there though King here
next ah it's not working out
I'm gonna take this pawn I think I have
it two different mates can't defend both
take here one of these two do I have it
I think I do if I took what the pawn
there is rook here yes back to
tournament whoa 40 40 oh my goodness
this guy's new huh up six hundred and
twenty three minutes and change is he in
a game he isn't a game oh he hasn't
preserved
um now this is the guy that gave me a
beating last time I can't king cobras
our town on him did it go in this
direction huh wow they're right I'm on
of seven maybe we get regular mate
regular mate is good too
don't forget about regular mates and I
get a regular mate h6 no h6 fishing-pole
could take here as well I guess we'll do
this step the King up
in trade I want these square for my King
making to threaten how do they stop that
they have to push I gotta push again
they didn't back determine forty four
forty thirty eight he slipped up oh okay
well even if he wins he isn't going to
get four points I want to keep this here
all right um let's do this very locked
King f7 I want to get Queen b6 in flush
that King back and there you go
I want to be careful about taking here
because it opens up this square for the
king
mmm
okay they invested some material now I
think I could take I have a discovery
but it's terrible one get some material
huh
take their yeah their King is far off
I'm up material and my king is even
closer I'm on the rook now that's a
double check and I could even take the
rook why not gotta stop that just get
rid of this guy I guess just want to
break this down
the bishop
here we go don't budge with that rook
whatever you do there we go back to
tournament and that's probably gonna do
it I don't think I'm gonna get paired up
again less than 30 48 with fire oh man
what an interesting tournament star
movement g5 I loved that one that was a
really really good shot that was really
really good I liked that a lot
a real lot cuz I was so tied up with
that pin on e4 and it was just blasted
open if I took F takes G you take double
check and oh man painful miss okay same
Bato second arc on third 33 players and
all in this one the pod Vinik tournament
let's have a look at page 2 3 & 4 a
small crew a good crew to the 32 of you
good games oh that is a lot of fun I
haven't played king of the hill in a
while so that was cool